okay so we have a new spider-man far
from home trailer at the beginning Tom
Holland gives this disclaimer he's like
if you haven't seen Avengers end game
don't watch this trailer because there
are spoilers in it and since I have to
talk about what's in the trailer if you
haven't seen Avengers end game if you're
not part of the group of people that
made that the second highest-grossing
film of all time in two weeks don't
watch this video because things are
gonna get spoiled for you holy [ __ ] that
thing is a force of nature isn't it but
if you're still here I assume you want
to hear me talk about the Spider Man far
from home trailer and some Avengers
endgame spoilers - all right so this
trailer gets right into it Peter
Parker's like I miss him I just see Tony
Stark forever I cuz like Iron Man
pictures on the wall he's talking to
happy Happy's like he wouldn't have done
what he did if he didn't know you'd be
here so you're like so they're just
talking about how Tony Stark's gone then
it gets into the trailer spider-man's on
vacation he's ghosting Nick Fury Nick
Fury finds him I guess Nick Fury is
running a form of shield that has
Quentin Beck aka Mysterio as part of it
they say in the trailer he's from
another world like the snap tore a hole
in their dimension and now like there's
a multiverse that's exposed to them now
which does open up the door to like
Miles Morales spider-gwen granted they
have their animations with Sony I'm just
saying it does open possibilities I do
not want that to be a possibility for
them to be like oh the multiverse Tony
Stark is alive of the multiverse Captain
America is young so he's still around
kicking ass and we could bring him back
into the MCU black widows a lot don't do
that [ __ ] it'll make all that stuff mean
nothing and that would just piss me off
I assume they know what they're doing
don't do that
but it's Mysterio Quentin Beck is a bad
guy maybe on his world he's a good guy
and Quentin Beck from this world will
find his tech and actually be an [ __ ]
actually when that be a twist the
possible bad Quentin back from this
world will kill the good one and then
take his place no one will actually know
and he causes problems or he's just
lying his ass off and he's actually
still an [ __ ] and he's just playing
him because he does have that I could
have used someone like you in my world
me shake spider-man's hands
what if what he meant to say was there
was one of you I killed his ass fun to
theorise that's I mean this this trailer
gives you the oh what's going on kind of
feeling but the fact that this Quentin
back is from another universe he's
probably from a universe where there was
not a lot a I'm Daenerys Targaryen
Abell it's so [ __ ] well this
sponsorship [ __ ] is out of control but
now there's a multiverse I wonder if
they're gonna use that to bring in a
bunch of spider-man villains from this
other place it's other universe people
have raised a very logical question of
how is everyone in Peter Parker's class
the same age like endgame does that
five-year jump so basically from the
snap to when they all get brought back
five years Ned Leeds is still in high
school I was like maybe Ned Leeds also
disappeared granted he looked like he
was like oh I missed you but and if
there was a snap and he also disappeared
and he came back he'd be like you saw
him yesterday but now we see everyone
else is also young so did everyone who
was a supporting role in spider-man
homecoming coincidentally disappeared
that might be a leap we have to just
accept but I love me a good spider-man
adventure I'm intrigued as to how
Quentin back plays into it is he good
right now is he bad is he just careless
and he gets a lot of people killed I
think it's like wait a minute you're
kind of out of control and now I gotta
take you out is he a dick from the
beginning and he's just playing them I
don't know but I feel like whatever
Quentin Beck is pitching whatever he's
saying I'm gonna take with a grain of
salt because master of illusion which
makes them master of deception right so
this new spider-man far from home
trailer have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]